the Joe Rogan experience I just are
using toothpaste again
soap job
I don't like toothpaste [ __ ] creeps
me out what yeah so no way yeah what are
you talking about yeah I liked well I'd
like to I don't have real teeth so it
doesn't matter no I mean your mouth like
you have a real tongue right glance over
the no real you're my 11th birthday we
just talked about this the other day
yeah who hate you my dad he was it look
it was no I'm joking it was a kid no
game it was no he was sick of you talk
to him like that huh that's where it
started I was a catcher and the I was a
passed ball I blocked it I picked it up
through my helmet off threw it down the
3rd and the kid tried to break up the
play and brought the bat back hit me in
the mouth knocked out knocked out [ __ ]
up 26 my team actually forgot to ask you
this what went in that part of this in
the story yeah my eleventh blue tie
you're you're you're playing catcher mhm
you throw the ball to make the play at
what third kid was steal a second to go
to third but so the batter has already
swung he already swung okay and now he
brings the bat back into my mouth
Oh like he just brought it back into my
mouth the spies like other so maybe I'll
pretend it's my full-motion yeah yeah
and brought it back in my mind on
purpose you know man I I don't I never
talked to the kid at all my teeth were
on home plate yeah you want to get real
about this this is you want to talk
about parenting my dad came out he's
like buddy it's gonna be okay your mom's
here we had a birthday party party
planned for me was my birthday my Danny
came out and in his hand he had my
fielder's glove and I went I was like
trying to get he goes take off the gear
Drew's gonna catch go over to shortstop
and I was like I don't have any teeth
here's again but if I take out now we
lose the game cuz I can't stop before
the fifth inning so go over finish the
game and I go I told you man this is my
my dad's a good dad it's not a bad guy
but he was like hey don't [ __ ] cry go
out finish inning it's one
it's one out and then we'll take you to
hospital so I wonder if shortstop I
don't know stuff like that I think turns
you stuff like that teaches you it
either breaks you or [ __ ] show up as a
guy or it makes you stronger as a guy
what do you think it did to you I don't
know man I've got a lot of those moments
with my dad where it's like be a [ __ ]
man and I'm glad he did it because
there's certain things like I want
though man
I remember being it that's not like a
suck it up moment that's like that no no
it's over
the game's over it doesn't matter is
over yeah a broken jaw everybody go home
he's getting knocked out it's very
likely there's some fractures in your
jaw and they could get infected like you
should be it's like a rush to get to the
hospital as quick as pasta you know your
dad was having like some sort of PTSD
I'm not in a world title fight
absolutely shortstop going this doesn't
seem fair this isn't that terrific my
dad's like I have to take you out now in
this game I mean I don't want to Jake he
was like he was like I'll give you some
Cheetos yeah I'm used to seeing people
get [ __ ] up and I think I'd have a
real problem with that I feel like I
would I think it's a different era is it
different I would I would panic brought
it up to my dad before yeah man he just
you know he laughs it off and he goes
you weren't that bad who can I ask a
question
shufoo in the game I have no idea I
wasn't there I went to the doctor doctor
Boza spent the rest of the day in the
get my teeth fixed how long did it take
before they fix your teeth Oh [ __ ] 20
years it took forever it was it was a
long period ninth grade in college
everything was fixed and I was 11 in
ninth grade I had like ninth grade I had
a smile I was comfortable with but yeah
I just have [ __ ] up teeth so it took
like three years for you got a smile you
were comfortable with
yeah so what was it before then just I
was like it was like spotty caps like
cosmetic dental dunno I was terrible
back it's terrible so it was like I want
to say like this is horrible I won't
feel like it was plastic caps it wasn't
like they stained really easy and so and
I had like two and then these were
broken and then
then at one point I just had four teeth
that looked okay and see and it's I mean
they're people listening right now that
are going through this but you just
cover your smile at times and you don't
enjoy life as much time with your mouth
closed you smile with your mouth closed
that's funny it's really funny to think
of you like that I know right yeah
that's why I am Who I am is when I got
teeth I was like
[Applause]